翻訳: Aya Klos
校正: Yoko Emori
皆さんには 私が音楽家であることが
分かると思います
私はこれまでに40年以上
プロのフルート演奏家
指揮者 作曲家 そして音楽評論家として
活動してきました
この40年間で
私は200以上の介護施設を訪問して
多くの「ディメンシャ」の
患者さんの前で演奏しました
「ディメンシャ」とは日本語でいう認知症です
今日私は 認知症の患者さんのために
音楽を使って行なっていることを
お話しします
話を進める前に
ここで私のオリジナル曲を
ご紹介したいと思います
その曲の題名は「Deserted Love
（置き去りにされた愛）」です
これは世界中の見捨てられた子供たちに
捧げるために作曲した曲です
祈りの曲です
楽しんでいただけたら光栄です
（フルート演奏開始）
（演奏終了）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
もしこれが普通の演奏会だったら
私と皆さんの間に距離があり
距離があっても大丈夫で 自然です
普通に感じるものですけれども
認知症の患者さんの前で演奏する時は
それでは ダメです
なぜですか？
なぜダメなのでしょうか？
なぜならば認知症の患者さんに演奏する時には
敬意と尊厳を表さなければいけません
そうしないと音楽は届かないです
どこに届かないのか？
音楽はどこに届かないのか？
患者さんの心に届かないわけです
ですから
どのように介護施設で 認知症の患者さんに
演奏するかを
ご紹介したいと思います
どうすればいいか 分かりますか？
皆さん既にお分かりですよね
今の演奏方法を覚えてますよね？
客席に入りましたよね？
ではちょっと解説させてください
３つの秘訣があります
１つ目の秘訣として
私は皆さんの非常に近くで演奏しました
お互いに手が触れてしまうくらいで
この近い距離感が非常に重要なわけです
２つ目の秘訣として
皆さんと同じ高さの目線で演奏しました
見上げることも 見下げることもなく
同じ高さの目線で演奏しなければなりません
そして３つ目の秘訣は
みなさんの目をずっと見ていました
お気づきだったでしょうか？
この３つの秘訣は
認知症の患者さんに
敬意と尊厳を示すのに
非常に役立ちます
ただ残念なことに
こうした接し方を ほとんどの
介護施設で見たことが全くありません
いや 全く見たことがないとは言えません
私が そうしていますから
認知症に関してですが
皆さんが その行動について
どのくらいご存知か分かりませんが
認知症の患者には 典型的な行動があります
もちろんその認知症の原因
にもよりますが
２つの側面があります
２種類のほぼ反対の行動を
されることがあるのです
見た目には ほぼ全く反対の行動です
１つ目はこのような感じです
一日中椅子に座って
動くことも 話すこともなく
ただ一日中静かに過ごします
このような場合
コミュニケーションが非常に難しいのは
反応しないからです
何を言っても
どのように話しかけたとしてもです
２つ目の行動の種類は
はるかに攻撃的なものです
こうした患者さんは
いつも怒っていてイライラされていて
いつも不平を言い 怒鳴っています
時として非常に気を付けなければいけない
こともあります
顔を殴られることが
あるかもしれないからです
実際に起こります
私も２回ほど そういった経験を
したことがあります
ですので覚えておいてください
このような２つの異なる行動を
示される患者さんがいても
信じられないかもしれませんが
原因は
理由は 同じなのです
認知症の患者さんは
この２つの異なる行動を取りますが
その理由は１つです
理由は何でしょうか？
その理由というのは 混乱と不安感です
患者さんの脳の中で多くの混乱が起きていて
それと同時に何かに恐れを
抱いていらっしゃるわけです
ですので もしこのような混乱と不安を
取り除きたければ
どうすればいいでしょうか？
私が やっているようなことです
音楽を奏で 歌を歌うことです
それから 今説明した３つの秘訣を
覚えておいてください
これにしたがって音楽を奏でれば
驚くほど早く 音楽に反応されます
本当にあっという間に反応されます
信じられないかもしれませんが
音楽は薬にも勝るものです
多くの薬を１度に何錠も飲んだとしても
それはすぐに効くことはないですよね
もしかしたら毒は一瞬にしてすぐに効いて
死ぬかもしれませんが 薬は違います
薬には 即効性はありません
ただ音楽には即効性があります
音楽は直ぐに効きます
ですので私が話を終える前に
あと１つ最後に覚えておいて
欲しいことがあります
世界中に多くの認知症の患者さんが
いらっしゃいますけれども
誰しも 内面は生きていらっしゃいます
内面 つまり脳の中と体の中ということです
そして 音楽こそが常に最大の引き金になり
記憶を呼び起こし 生命力を呼び戻すのです
それが 音楽の力です
私はこれを強く信じていますし
もし皆さんも私と同じようにすれば
多くの世界中の認知症の患者さんを
救うことができると思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）